back another impromptu stream I'm
probably just going to play this
tournament and that will be all
it's my daily daily dose of chess which
is longer than one minute just sticking
with London system
I go to opening for whites
this is usually a fun line white targets
b7 black plays Queen b6 we end up
trading Queens white gets a file at some
point let's play Knight of three seems
like this guy knows what he's doing
playing very quickly but as far as I can
tell the position is very plasma for
whites
I do have 95 this should be a good move
let's play Knight a5 anyway we'll trade
and then I'm gonna try and get a rook to
the B file somehow but he wants to play
e5 mm play King d2 and 94 check but
White has a bishop here so it can't be
that dead to play Bishop g3 and then
still a 5
Bishop g3 e5
maybe at three restricting the night
then kingi - let's do that
I don't play Bishop each - probably
Bishop H - so it doesn't get hidden
certain lines I should be live I
literally started the stream right when
the tournament started so I haven't had
a chance to check if this is actually
working
hopefully it is I got three if anyone's
watching right now I do have the chat
open let me know if he was okay I've
added a like some kind of audio filter
which is supposed to reduce background
noise I hope it didn't like mute the
whole thing he probably checked that
let's play King bee - so he wants to put
the knight on b5 perhaps let's play
Bishop to e3 this is going to be a long
grind
especially f5 do anything there's Beth
I'd if we could trade I don't think it
does anything let's play bracket one my
belongings are a four or maybe even be
four so he'll probably dominate the
e-file but there's no like penetration
square you choose covered which is
important he's not playing Ricky aids
let's try the pair of Brooks at some
point I might want to take on p5 because
whatever he takes back with then I'll
have some plot break potential pawn
break maybe right now take
let's do it objectively it's probably
equal but maybe Y can push for something
ip8 might be a good move he plays my p8
I might just take it now he can't play
Knight P aids his might doesn't really
have a great place apart from c6 in this
position let's play Bishop here for h4
okay let me make sure the audio is
working no one's in the chat can I be
heard okay
it was working sweets good to know
so he wants to play Knight g6 it's
played for will trade or if we don't
trade I'll trade we're going to trade at
some point an h-file will open I could
play h5 now let's take the play with
each one so yeah relatively equal but
I'm gonna try and put as much pressure
as possible and either get him low in
time or provoke some kind of blunder
throw in this check
Oh 96 is coming though that's gonna be
annoying
okay a change of hands can see three
rookie 1 I have to defend maybe g4 at
some point I think White's just stuck
what to do
I can play rook like a player gage -
I'll play King g6 we repeat but I want
to repeat lay up for my 4 is very risky
she's rookie for in the end
Oh gage 6 checking g7 it's probably not
worth it move back
I have a trick though I'll see if he
falls into it please take the bishop you
didn't take the bishop hmm probably
didn't realize you could take I think
the only way I'm gonna win this is time
or f4u trade everything put my bishop on
d2 to the Fen b4 and I want my king
somewhere more useful I have to take
some fun
oh I hung up on no it's over pushing
this i think it's stole oh it's not
still drawing he's winning but can i
trick him my gosh she's winning all the
pawns
this is really bad I need some miracle
let's do that
I Bishop is so restricted night see to
please no okay that was really bad i
over pushed i had to accept a drama i
played that for which maybe not the
losing move not a good move giving this
night is so dominant I'm gonna be right
back
you
you
okay I'm back not even in the top
hundred your one loss that was a long
game - I'm gonna try and recover from
that and let's preserve this game will
try London one more time
good thing the leader only has six
points so it's still time to catch up
96 is usually not a great move but it's
playable I've never seen the chat so
empty no no one's communicating but okay
whatever gives me more time to focus its
place in five
I'll trade whites not really a lot
better here actually but it's a type of
position that hopefully I cannot play
Hannah we go for this e4 break just
expand probably defend the sepal on yeah
this is very nice position just complete
control over the center the question is
how to proceed probably f4 attempting to
somehow trap the Bishop a5 might
actually be a threat because after take
take I'm attacking he 7 as well also
threatening to trap the rook with Bishop
a8 or Bishop f3 attacking 8 so all his
pieces are potentially a target in this
position if I probably a good move
you five looks tempting but probably oh
if I've loses a queen let's not play you
five
let's play Bishop at three you before
it's kind of annoying let's play a three
this position takes work I thought my
center was really nice but it takes more
than a nice Center to win a game so the
next several moves are probably just
going to be improving moose and King
each one the King belongs in the corner
if he plays before then it gives me
something to play against wood we can
see 400 I just got a message you
mentioned something you mentioned a chat
with silence so is a chat actually
working because it's usually never the
silent but people are communicating what
what is going on um do I have the wrong
chat open or did I like do I ban myself
somehow okay let's focus on this game
and then try and figure out what's going
on with the chat or I'll just figure it
out during this game oh so now I see the
chat but why is a chat not working on
the other page
huh refresh chat okay so the the way I'm
going to try and win this position is
some kind of King side attack like Rick
g1 oh so now I see the chat so axe
villager is here sir grumpy bear some
how refreshing actually worked don't
want to do I want to play fast that's
true actually the H file is the line in
which I should attacks like rook h1
Bishop b4 I want to trade off the lights
great bishops
maybe I should have traded off like
square bishop because now I can't access
h1 but it's still okay maybe it's not
okay I'm gonna try he's playing well
though but maybe not anymore oh no he
has he has a move but please don't play
it please don't play it yes
you didn't play rook takes c3 that's
also a good move though this is bad but
I can take and take on g6 14 seconds
left
still a scary position rook be through
your rooks III is coming
I just want to trade Queens okay thank
you that was a good move
I'm stacking my bishop those are three
pawns are annoying now the goal is to
[ __ ] him oh no the goal is not to hang a
rook well that was nice such a messy
game okay pretty sure I can win this
that was such a low quality game
especially towards the end there he had
well he had work to take rip to c3 in
this position just winning McQueen
bishop c3 also looked strong at first
but gave me play and then somehow like
this is just much better for late but at
the time situation regretfully was a
good move
I didn't want him to start checking me
okay let's not look at that anymore
let's go back so I do get the berserk
points
I moved from out of the top hundred to
number 33
the laughing profits go go go kill them
okay that's nice
ex villager as far as I can see look at
audio is good
great okay thirty-six minutes pretty bad
start to the tournament I'm in the
desert the rest of the games going for
the win let's play a Spanish if he plays
my c6 haven't played a Spanish in a
while Bishop c5 this is one of the
reasons I don't play Spanish it's
because black has so many different
lines it's hard to know them all
I'm just gonna play I'm gonna try and
play normal noobs during the night to g3
put the pawn on c3 Bishop will go to e3
and most likely if I'm not mistaken I'm
pretty sure this is called the mid cog
variation like this early Queen f6 named
after a pretty strong player from
Illinois Nikola Macross who I just saw a
few days ago let's play c3 just going
with the typical Spanish rounds
that's flicking each to just extra safe
the bishop will go to e3 very soon
wait 9 an f4 is sometimes an annoying
attacking piece but if I can just ignore
it and play around it that's the
ultimate goal
g5 so ambitious in blocks doing all the
typical like attacking moves but he
might regret it later let's play d4
the bishop most likely dropping back to
c2 Queen g7 I could take on that for 9h
five
I think that's winning upon you could
play Queen eh-eh didn't keep the attack
on d4 or not
Queen eh it was maybe the the best try
for Knight d5 okay this is looking good
yeah that's the thing like with these
positions if that goes for the early
attack sometimes white just has to
weather the storm and then something
like this will happen where black just
runs out of fuel
wow so many fans a laughing prophet
Daniel Moreno thanks for the support
oh he wants to check me at me on g2
maybe that's favor
some point I want to play 9h for tonight
g6 if he allows me I am back in the u.s.
I've actually been back in the US since
February first and so whoa he's asking
for night g6 you can't stop it I could
pre move it'd probably be okay
unless he plays 95 no okay okay so two
wins in a row that game was probably the
cleanest game that I've played so yeah
that's why I'm streaming at a more
normal time it's like about 2:30 Central
Time so I'll be back in the US for at
least a month or two debating whether to
go to the Bangkok open that's in April
but we'll see
okay let's buzzer again still not within
distance of the leader Wow let's play e5
this game usually if I'm going for a
quick win I'll play d5 go for some
Marshall something if he allows it so if
you play c3 I would play d5 that's a
Marshall a four is an anti Marshall but
sometimes can still make it happen d5
take take take take take
probably not let's play Bishop e7
now maybe d5 makes some sense because my
bishop on b7 protects and helps attack
in some positions he doesn't take the
pawn so this should be okay for black
but what to do Bishop c5 now if he takes
tix
if he takes takes time attacking c3 so
he can't he doesn't have time 25p fix IX
I've been I've been kind of around the
world in the last three weeks I've been
in Thailand Singapore London New York
City and now back in Chicago so a lot of
traveling it's tiring so now this is a
very positional game where we have
basically identical structure but I like
Spock I like blacks position more just
because my bishop is active and this
bishop is passive and maybe I can I
don't know build up pressure somehow a
he force a target
Mickey with he would love to somehow
move his night somewhere and play f3 but
don't think he has time how long you've
been streaming for today I've only been
streaming for like half hour my lifetime
I've been streaming since October I want
to say October November let's play g6
restrict this night maybe h5 next oh he
wants to fight for the file because if I
take he takes with King makes sense /
then I can take on a4 oh no the bishop
defense
I can play Bishop c6 just not seeing
things correctly today
I'm just working slower than normal now
I can win 84 I think
okay up upon outside passer life is good
I still have to work to win this less
than a minute and nights can be tricky
simplifications are probably good King
activity is also good so the plan is to
at some point use my a pawn as a decoy
also to move quickly it's interesting
move let's play this now he's constantly
tied down to e4 and I think I'll just
start pushing my a pawn
you should have enough time to win this
but you never know
okay now I'm just trying to checkmate
him somehow let's do that I have to get
my knight to see - let's take upon he's
gonna try and check me somehow what's
going on here
I think blacks just winning but it's
tricky he's a knight b5 no seven sevens
enjoying this I guess
wait I have to sack my pawn what is this
I guess he's playing for a win if he
plays for a win maybe I could find that
was weird so if I flagged I would have
lost cuz I have the pawn and I guess
checkmates are possible okay there is no
excuse for not winning that but it was
tricky like how do I get my night to see
to quickly enough
oh maybe King a three and then get night
my night to be three but then he was my
he five I can't draw arrows so King a
395 oh man
I have 92 just stopping night c4 and
threatening Knight B 3 all right P okay
so my goal before this tournament was to
break 2400 but now I guess it's to stay
above 2300 given my performance let's go
break again any chance for me to to come
back and finish in first probably Matt
do I have I still have less than 10
points
ouch
chess is tough so I'm going to try and
be more aggressive than normal hopefully
get some quick attack and go for this 9h
5-4 combine that with like Bishop g4 oh
he's my Tiki five though we'll start
slowly I guess I could play nine of four
right away or even some like night my g4
okay I'll go for d5
I don't want to lose upon stinger 87
thanks for following I haven't really
been looking at the follows but I do
appreciate all the followers okay going
for a 904 I have some funny idea of
playing a 5 rook at 6 9 H 546 but it's
probably just a fantasy
I'll be the the better and clicker idea
is to play my h5 Queen g5 then I have
like 3 minor pieces and my queen doing
some nice attacking I want to play f5 at
some points but it does block the bishop
it makes his bishop slightly more
annoying um start with this my
threatening they take F 2 I take F 2 I'm
just gonna do it without calculating as
it looks fun
probably unsound but okay if he takes
with night I win on you three if he
takes with rook I take on g3 take on h3
yeah I don't know what's going on
I'm definitely not catching the leader
Ganesh
nine five seven so Brooke h2 rogue h2 93
my Queens trapped that's not good
let's take on g4 first take care slime
down a piece but I have funds so it's
not at the end of the world g5 f 6 I
have four connected passed pawns h5 s
coming Ortega 4 is also coming very
unclear it's t5 sweet
let's just defend yeah he's playing well
I'm gonna lose a bunch of pawns but I'm
gonna try and keep it complicated enough
to to try and Fagin efore was hanging I
still have 3 passed pawns but they're
hard to push forward
well maybe not anymore for cones
this is why I like in games it's all
about pushing pawns
okay a very messy game somehow my attack
didn't work I sacrificed very unsound me
got a lost position but then I had puns
was working in 85
well do some reverse Grand Prix if he
lets me the pots are fish thanks for
following
I'm try and make it in oh I'm already in
the top ten
we'll try and make it to the top five so
this is very similar to like just a
standard Grand Prix where the idea is
Queen h5 at for Bishop h3 all the
standard attacking ideas h3 makes life
given more fun I think it's fun to
attack when you're not down material by
h4 decent moves
it's my queen h6 yes g5 here which I
kind of forgot about but still might be
good for black I don't know what's going
on in this position I should take a
screen IH for Queen g5 take on e7
take take yeah I don't want to sack
everything let's just take I have a G
file down material though thanks for the
follow the name disappeared I think it
was like no oriental or something thank
you uh he wants to play trick g1 that's
good move
it's just build up as much as possible
what to start with start with Queenie
tries
sack everything it might be mates if I
suck everything but it might not be our
re you disco thanks for the follow
actually don't know the idea with this
905 move
maybe not h6 there yun sounds good move
let's play trippy eights if I can't win
over the board I can try and flag him so
he's letting me take on h3 but I don't
know if I want to take right now play
Ritchie ate first
like white just seems really stuck like
this Bishop can't move the King stuck
the rooks are both kind of stuck so
that's the thing with having too many
pieces they they just get stuck together
I can take Ani to get some pawns I
didn't want to trade Queens but now I
think I do and Black has not lost a
single pawn hunger Kunstler thanks for
following so I think the goal for this
game is to not lose any pawns just to
keep everything
let's stick with Bishop c6 yeah I do
have to play fast let's trade a pair of
Brooks and my king will be on g7 you
can't really break through not easily at
least okay I didn't want to trade Brooks
but his rook is probably more useful
than mine oh no I lost a pawn no okay
this is bad
the seven pawns to five pawns so two
pawns for the bishop okay
still hope before coming it's easier to
play for black I think it's again just
just about pushing pawns I should now
I'll leave my pawns there and hopefully
make him think a bit more bring my King
around I'm just trying to flag him I
think it's I know if it's winning for
white or if it's drawn but time is going
to tell the story
I want to repeat the position okay
I feel dirty doing that but okay he
should have won Maki and so time is
always a factor uh so I mean I only have
one losses tournament did I draw a game
- I think I drew a game yeah
but the quality of play I do apologize
playing so poorly all the work as well
it's five four and we'll go with some
perk I guess modern play my secret prep
not really h4 and the whole idea with h4
is just to discourage black from
castling kingside but he might do so
anyway it's Castle queenside b1
he also castles Queen side
I play g3 to play Bishop g2 Bishop h3
let's play d5 that was Bishop has less
influence in the position he wants to
attack it's interesting things got very
passive for light very quickly but I'm
still alive that was a good move
I'm just trying to keep his bishop
closed it would be terrible for me to
take on that floor there at some point
maybe g4 scary attack let's play g4
the stream is getting a bit laggy Sh
I'm sorry about that is it your internet
connection or is it me never tell
hopefully it's not me actually like
whites position now like the king is
safe for the time being I might be
losing h4 but he might be losing h5
this might be the last game that like
actually counts for the tournament what
to do you wants to play rook c2 let's
play Bishop d3 that was a big move up on
time I can relax not too much he wants
to play Bishop d4 it's putting 92
prophylaxis well trade Queens and flag
him I'm flagging too many people today I
apologize I should try and win over the
board but what to do oh maybe I'll win
over the board or maybe he'll flag okay
back to tournaments one more game maybe
I could break into the top three well I
would have to win in like less than two
minutes okay I hope the connection is
okay I have the green square in OBS so I
think that's a good sign
hello nitrous-oxide long time no see
yeah well the tournament is closed now
that's sad fifth place
I probably deserves much lower just
based on the games
yeah we'll move on
one thing I'm trying to do every day
which I think I'll do right now is just
some like training
antics because I do have a tournament
coming up next
or this coming weekend and I want to
make sure that I'm doing something
beneficial for my chess so what I'm
gonna do is minimize the chats and nice
all of these other random windows and
just focus on where is it I don't have
it open focus on some puzzles I think
what I'll do is I'll do five of these
and then see where I go from there so
and I will talk through a thought
process try and hold myself accountable
so White's move let's back up to pawns
goes up to pawns but f7 is hanging hmm
I'm pretty sure like as I solve more
problems or rating or the the difficulty
gets Oh am I trying to say as my rating
goes higher the problems get more
difficult so this could be a difficult
problem when Queen take f7 and Bishop to
go 7 both are pretty forcing but black
just plays communicates and then what g5
is also hanging
we completely wrecked a key 5b attacking
the bishop and then Bishop it probably
needs to be defended or move somewhere
and then we take on a seven and then we
have rookie a check so for example like
rook taking five let's say Bishop e6
then we have Queen's egg of seven I was
thinking if he plays community chick
this rookie Yates so you would probably
play King h7 it seems like the best line
for white we're taking five I think
black can't counterattack in any way
this with Bishop b4 is a move but then
still Queen take f7 then even c3 and
then so it rook take you five Bishop e6
Queen take up 17 h7 I don't see a clear
wind but it looks good so this is going
to be six in that line
this is a type of position I think if
this were like a game you can start with
rook take five and then think depending
on where black moves so I'll start with
your tv5 Queen d7 really so we can just
take the Queen and take on on a5 or I
could take on f7 first but taking on our
seven first teenage shades and the
bishops hanging in the end so we have to
take on d7 and just from the piece I'm
curious about that slime Bishop b6
how do I move the pieces oh this should
be six sir okay
because I was calculating this and then
this is arrow in here oh maybe there's
rook e8 ooh
Ricky eight and then if taketake were
threatening Bishop to G its and that's
very hard to stop and G six runs into
Queen G aids let's just check that with
stockfish so Queen d7 of course of
computer move okay by Bishop d6 what is
going on Bishop e6 Queens ik 1787 who
not rookie a rookie seven
why not Ricky eight rook take F to
really Quincy eighteen g6 man sock fish
is so good
this just looks almost winning for white
but I guess it's completely winning for
black
Oh cuz whatever it checks on e6 is
racast six with the counter check that's
painful
and why is ricky seven so winning ro
take f2o the Queen defends uh-huh
I guess White's just finding c3 Wow
cuz this queen is tied down to g7 okay
that problem would have been really
difficult if black
alright the the main movements Bishop e6
and I had to find this whole line like
rookie 7 and that her key aides but okay
cool problem we'll move on so it seems
like they are getting more difficult
though Knight c3 lights up upon the
night's not defended though so moves
like Knight take out 3 are something
attractive also night at five extra
Knight a5 Bishop d2 Bishop takes c3
Bishop takes c3 93 looks when looks like
it wins material so 9 of 5 white has
Knight d5
yeah 595 what is going on
ooh so neither 595 Black has a very nice
move whoever is watching if you want to
find it pause the stream but the move is
Queens 85 Pont 85 I take you three and
black will be other bishop in the end so
let's do it
cool I thought that turn on starfish
okay so that was that was only two
problems try three more I like to move
White's down a piece but the king is on
e8 seems like there's a lot of candidate
moves here like taking on g6 taking 97
taking on c6 Queen c7 so many candidate
moves these positions are tough because
there's so much to choose from and you
can like look at one move and then spend
several minutes just calculating one
move and then usually overlooked another
movie
so I'm glancing over like all the
candidate moves and trying to figure out
if anything really pops out I'm actually
curious can black castle in this
position I should probably look at the
game the key never move okay so black
can castle either way potentially so
that means a move like rook c1 could be
met with simply kingside castling
queenside castling
I mean Queens a g6 if the King moves to
the defilers roti one if the King moves
to f8 I actually don't see anything
looks okay for black Wow there's also
potential in this position to gesture
like try and trap the Queen like rook d1
the Queen's not going to get trapped but
rook to u1 might be just a good
improving move
this is tough though
looking at weensy southern kingside
castle if this were a blitz i would
probably play rope t1 as it looks looks
like it just improves and then if the
Queen drops back to b6 it's just a
better version of the position actually
having calculated these lines with rook
take e7 Jack probably should so quaint a
g6 King at favorite-- eggie 7 King take
you seven rook e1 the King starts
running we could win the Queen in that
line but then there's two rooks for a
queen so probably not decisive
funny movie 92 92 McQueen you just drops
back to thank d7 wow this is tough this
problem light and my amazing streak cuz
I'm really not sure who take
ninety-seven immediately and then play
rookie one but doesn't seem any better
than that other line
I'm tempted to look at the chat and see
what people are saying good I'm gonna
try and uh I'll try and come up with
some attempt and then go back and look
so Brooke Brooke cd1 the Queen has like
three squares a 7 B 6 and C 4 say Queen
C 4 it's it's one of these positions
it's got to be good but like how is it
good work T 1 Queen C 4 Queens AG 6 King
outfit Brooke take you seven can take
you seven
I don't know what else to look at as I'm
missing something really easy in Queen
tg6 King f8 Queen at 5:10 Bishop f6 so R
up do you won Queen c4 like moves moves
like Queen d6 or just met with castling
this is nothing long as I spent pretty
sure on any given problem it's tough I
might be overlooking something very
simple
tikki 7 Ricky wand there's all these
resources dirty ones a resource clean
tech g6 as a resource for tiki sevens a
resource so I have a feeling it's about
combining them in the right way let me
start with Rick d1 Queen c4 Queens a g6
King f8 and then worked 87 Kings 87
Queen take g7 and at Queen f7 there's
rook e1 if Keeney a Lee just take on h8
if Heaney 6teen e6 for a few one King up
five I'll just calculate to mate just
for fun King at five rookie five King F
for Queen g3 mate okay so that actually
gives me some hope that rook t10 right
move because if rook t1 we're driving
away the Queen from defending the g7
pawn which is important in this line
when we take on e6 and take on you side
and take on g7 so the line I just
calculated just to double check rook d1
Queen c4 Queen take g6t my fates direct
a g7 King take g7 Queen take g7 I think
this line apply or this line can be
played if the Queen moves to be six or a
seven
and then once the King gets see seven we
take on g7 King e6
uh what was the line I said q6
rook e1 oh yeah and if King d6 is
Queenie seven mate
if King at five there's Ricky five king
F for Queen G three mates
it's a lot of arrows let's see if it
works
are you serious
mommy chess at least give me some
satisfaction like playing that long
mates that was a really good problem as
it was difficult and rook d1 is a hard
move to find but they have to they have
to have you like play the right lioness
like Queen C fourth maybe there's a
couple wins maybe that's why like these
sort of tactics trainer problems if
there's a couple wins they want to avoid
those sort of situations but I unpleased
I was able to to actually calculate and
conclude rookie ones that was the best
move just to show for people who maybe
didn't follow if Queen C for this is a
key line I'm pretty sure I'll check a
stock fish but yeah the king is just too
exposed here here king g6 Queen d7 mates
so King f5 sure this is one of many
potential mates so just to confirm
stalkerish Wow Rick do you want only
winning move yeah cuz the problem is
like a lot of other moves just give time
for back to Castle and then Queen c4
take and rook take e7 only winning move
so they should definitely have this line
played out Queen jg7 only winning move
and then there's a bunch of wings okay
f3 or f4 okay
but of course Ricky you won cool let's
do one more problem and I'll probably on
the stream are you serious is that just
a free piece we went from such a
difficult problem so just taking a free
knight on e5 I'm missing something
Queen f6
okay let's actually catch it Queen f6 f4
I think that's the only calculation if
he plays 95 then we just whatever sac up
on okay x4 right
I still have Queen h5 here but then g6
let's play f4 ok yeah that problem
deserves zero points it is interesting
though that f4 might be the only winning
move but ok I'm gonna end it there I
will look at the chat try and address
anyone who might have questions Wow a
lot of people watching new record
scrolling up here Oh X storm 59 what's
up mister and AK is in the chat nope
rack with the quotes slim g77 how's it
going Brayden Laughlin more puzzles I
don't think I missed anything two
notable my sick duck how's it going ok I
think I'm gonna end it there keeping the
streak at least with puzzles hello esta
Chen you joined at the wrong time but I
will be back I might even be back this
evening depending but yeah I'll be back
at various points this week so so long
for now and I will see you guys in the
future
bye